the transition after the Soviet Union
fell to Russia and Yeltsin was not a
smooth one by any means uh you know as I
say at the end of the book it's not like
they lived happily ever after yeah uh
but my point broader point is you take
the wins when you can get them uh people
now had access to passports they don't
have to have uh they can leave the
country they have food they have access
to information it's somewhat censored
but it's certainly nothing like it was
uh under the Soviet Union
um and they didn't have to live in this
kind of
constant fear and they had opportunities
and it's such a step forward uh um and
there was this one great moment and I'm
good there's a super Boris Yeltsin
became president of Russia he's also
mayor of Moscow at one point or the
equivalent of Mayor
and he came here to visit NASA on in the
in the capacity of one of the other and
while he was there he went to visit a
supermarket it was a Randall's then I
think it's a food town now it still
exists I'm gonna go there I'm gonna
start bawling
and as he's looking around like he had
never seen so much food and this is food
that like even wealthy people in Russia
don't have access to and there's
pictures of him just like this like what
and the scene that really was poignant
to me is on his flight back he's sitting
there on the plane like this
and he's like they had to lie to the
people because if they knew they
wouldn't have been able to get away with
it and that's the moment where it's just
like oh this wasn't like skewed
propaganda you know this was like they
knew and it was a lie from A to Z and he
was just like holy crap just like and
you could just imagine him on that plane
his brain reprogramming because if
you're taught since you're a kid and he
was no he was an older man he was no
dummy you think okay the Americans are
starving and poor and they're lynching
people every day and then you go to a
supermarket the most banal place on
Earth and you see like I think when the
article said like they couldn't believe
how big the onions were or something
like that and you're seeing this and
you're seeing these like janitorial
School teachers these aren't dignitaries
and they're regular people just picking
whatever they want and you're just like
like you you it's like the equivalent of
having a stroke
I do think that that's one of the most
powerful things is the grocery the
grocery store as that guy in terms of
drawing a distinction between the two
systems yeah because uh you know you
could have like technology you can show
off technology and so on but you can
kind of sign up write off Technologies
like okay that's the mechanism
uh of the devil but when you look at
just
uh
fruit and veggies and like very big
fruit and veggies and like yeah and
fruit in particular like certain kinds
of fruit that are just not available in
Russia
I mean it's yeah that really shows wait
a minute
it's uh interesting like when you're
older and you have to face the reality
that uh what you believe to be true that
your whole life has been based on a set
of lies and your stuff not not mistakes
not like a little bit like blatant lies
from top to bottom start to finish that
I don't know what that's like